mark when you were first creating space
command was it in your mind that you
were going to attempt to sell it to a
studio it's really interesting you know
when i started in television i think
I've been a professional writer since i
was 19 I still actually in truth my
first radio play erred when I was 18 on
kpfk my first short story I told was 19
I start writing my first book when I was
22 the twilight zone companion and I was
writing for television by the time I was
22 or 23 and when i started in
television if you wanted your work to
reach millions of people it had to be
through a studio and a network and there
were only three networks ABC NBC and CBS
and also PBS you know public television
and that was it and so now and also you
have to shoot on 35 millimeter or 16 and
you edited on a movie ola and it was it
costs millions of dollars to make any
television program per episode now of
course it's very very different you can
shoot on a digital camera we own a red
and you you added on the laptop our
editors back at our place right now
editing Space Command on our laptop and
hook it up to our big-screen TV and and
and you can reach out to your audience
your audience can help finance what
you're doing and you can also reach it
reach millions of people via the
Internet so you know a lot of people
stay stuck in the way things used to be
and I think that's a big mistake I
embraced the new model and I love the
new model and i love the direct
communication with my audience i feel
that i'm the same as my audience and so
as I like something if I'm enthusiastic
about something I know my audience will
be too and and some of Space Command
initially my idea was I 20 my first came
up with the idea of doing a hopeful
vision of the future it's his
multi-generational saw that the causes
150 years in the future takes place in
the solar system and beyond and a lot of
my son's run network shows and a number
of them said to me we know this and we
can team up and we can walk this into a
network and get a pilot deal but I knew
from experience that if i sold it in a
probably would sell I'd be hired to
write the script and then the network
was cut it off its script and then they
would own it no one would ever see it or
they could greenlight the production of
the pilot and then we shoot the pilot
and if they didn't greenlight it to
series again no one would ever
you or if they you know related series
they might have notes that would screw
it up and ruin it oh so I thought well
no let me see if i can raise money i'd
never raised money before but I said
let's let's see if I can reach out to
the audience i mentor thousands of young
people in Hollywood well actually people
of all ages via the round table I run in
the classes I teach and I've been
hearing about crowdfunding and so I
thought well let's see if I could do
that so um our target was seventy five
thousand dollars to raise in two months
we hit that in three days and we kept
going and we raised two hundred twenty
one thousand dollars and that i sold
investment shares to my backers and
raised another half-million and we're
still going strong and so that was
enough to open our own studio shoot the
first two hours of Space Command shoot
30 minutes of the second two hours after
in the first eight hours now mind hours
9 through 12 sets of season so then the
question is well do I want to take it to
a network do is there reason to take it
to a network if you've got them as much
of a head of steam there are over 500
scripted comedies and dramas on all the
various networks and platforms now 500
series the cost of rolling out a show
promoting it just so people know it
exists is 23 million dollars I can raise
enough money to make space commit I
can't raise enough money to promote
Space Command oh that's where a studio
and a network or more ideally more
specifically a network or big platform
like Netflix or Amazon makes sense
because I really want to reach a world
audience on a broad scale if I want this
to really laughs and and reach the
people I want to reach that makes a lot
of sense and the fact that matters that
he started out wondering would be a
single film and what happened was once
we started with the crowdfunding
something that we hadn't seen as an
aspect of crowdfunding wasn't just
gathering money to shoot something but
it was gathering awareness worldwide yes
and that awareness through us because
both so funny people we said maybe if
you other people are really down on the
star trend and will want to see
something that's hopeful hopeful vision
of the future and in fact the outpouring
was so great that's what ignited this
crazy ambition in the ad what productive
and it started to grow and grow and grow
maybe two maybe three and so although
certain single it became a much larger
story right and became you know how I
ongoingly and we've had investors just
walk up to him and say I invested in
this because I wanted to say something
that gave me hope yes specifically yeah
until we realized that something that
was troubling to us was profoundly
troubling to vast numbers all cross well
you know it's funny because during our
Space Command campaign I got a phone
call and it turns out that there's a
real Space Command it's the space going
arm of the United States Air Force and
they called me a major in the Air Force
called me I thought oh gosh they're
either going to want to shut me down or
have me changed the name and I got on
the phone with major Glenn Roberts of US
Air Force because we love what you're
doing we want to be part of it great so
but the funny part is doing our campaign
if you type Space Command into Google we
came in first in the Air Force came in
second and even to this day if you type
in Space Command the air force comes in
first and we come in second even still
so millions of people on the world know
about Space Command thousands gave us
money and which is very very heartening
but yes definitely was saying originally
it was going to be 12 our story and I
actually wrote half of it before the
campaign and then immediately sat down
afterwards and the second half of that
to our script but because i was doing
media interviews every single day of the
campaign as i talked about Space Command
the story started to grow in my mind and
Elaine said it grew to from two hours 24
hours to 6 hours to eight hours and
finally was a whole series and so when I
sat down all of the first so what had
was originally going to be the first two
hours ultimately became the fourth story
the fourth two-hour story and so I sat
down all of the other script so the
first one the first the 744 of the to
our script already and and what was
going to be the first one is now going
to be the fourth one so if you ever go
back to our original Kickstarter
campaign the active I'm talking about as
being in space command actually now are
in that fourth one so it's armin
shimerman from Deep Space Nine and Buffy
Christina Moses who just hardened
containment Ethan Phillips from Star
Trek Voyager etc so sort of like a loose
26 more Marquis well yeah well the lung
thing is that all the actors I
approached
many of them stars from shows I've
worked on said yes and so I mean my
friend mark Mike Lonnie from Orange is
the new black and does jones who starred
in pans labyrinth and Hellboy and the
strain he's going to be starting the new
Star Trek TV show Star Trek discovery
and mira furlan from Babylon 5 and lost
and Bill movie from Babylon 5 and lost
in space and Bob Picardo from Star Trek
Voyager and starkly Stargate Atlantis
he's a wonderful actors James Hong who
was in Blade Runner and Big Trouble in
Little China he's one of my heroes he's
phenomenal to work with and Ferrante
here who was in JJ Abrams Star Trek
movie and iron man and you know Elysium
I mean these are phenomenal actors and
and I'm honored to be working with an
adjusted to such a joy
you